euromax highlights and here's your host
ann o'donnell
hello and welcome to euromax highlights
where we put together all of the best
reports of the week for you here's a
sneak peek at what's coming up
magic of the moment for photographer
thomas hubker timing is everything
back on the case author agatha
christie's detective urkul
has a new adventure
and fun in the forest in finland we
visit ulu and its outlying regions
but for the past 60 years thomas huebker
has documented major historical events
with his images now the german
photographer has compiled his work in a
photo book wunderlist he's also been
honored with a retrospective in cologne
and has won the leica hall of fame award
the former president of the magnum photo
agency has traveled the world with his
camera capturing moments in time during
the cold war tragic events such as 9 11
as well as everyday life
senses it
the split second the instant that
captures the moment
and transforms photography into art
a lot of time and a lot of patience
and you have to deal with lots of failed
attempts
that sometimes the moment you hope for
isn't going to come
but sometimes you get lucky
at this year's photokina trade fair in
cologne pictures from his six decade
career are on display at the leica
gallery
leading periodicals such as stan and geo
commissioned hoopka to take pictures of
people and landscapes all over the world
the images leave their mark
especially since nothing is manipulated
i prefer to stay undercover so to speak
and try not to be seen just observing
standing somewhere in the corner and
thinking this could become a picture if
i'm lucky
these photos were taken while he was
still at school
his talent for composition was already
evident
soon he started working for major
international publications
he took these pictures in 1970s east
germany he was the first west german
photographer to get permission
the only decoration visible at this not
very attractive housing project was eric
honaker
and on such a gloomy day it kind of hits
you in the gut
i also like this one because it shows
how people found a niche for themselves
that's how people found some space for
themselves to simply be human
and not to be completely swallowed up by
the state machine
the trade fair also presents the latest
advances in photographic equipment
thomas hupka is also interested in new
technologies
in 1989 he became the first german
member of the renowned magnum photo
agency
and later was made president
one of magnum's rules is to only depict
reality that's also his motto whether
working digitally or with film
that must happen
at the time you'd think twice about a
shot because there were only 36 pictures
per roll of film so we worked more
sparingly it was good training because
you knew that the supply of film was not
endless
and you'd have to load a new roll of
film
or sometimes i'd forget the film at the
hotel and i'd have to go back
hupco's photo essays on muhammad ali
were unrivaled
he went to the u.s several times in the
1960s
and no one else was able to get as close
to the outspoken boxer
his most famous picture came by accident
during a training session
during the break he saw us sitting in
the dark and came up to us he hadn't
seen us at first and he said hi how are
you how are you
and i had my camera ready
and i shot three pictures
in these
his image of 911 also became famous
thomas
is an old-school all-rounder revered by
young photographers too
i have been wandering around the world
for the past 40 years always looking for
something going on
you get an instinct for it
you see that there might be something
there
something might happen
now famous himself hupka finds people
taking his picture
but he still prefers to have his own
finger on the button
well he's been billed as the new journey
for saturday fausto pulisi is a
promising new italian designer on the
scene and the sicilian was tasked with
reviving the fashion house of ongaro
back in 2012 but he also has his own
label he got his big break when the
material girl madonna discovered his
talents since then felici has been
creating her outfits for tours as well
as dressing katy perry nicki minaj and
beyonce we caught up with him during
milan fashion week
handmade roman sandals strong patterns
in bold combinations and everything just
a little over the top
that's what fausto pulisi has in mind
for urban gladiators next spring and
summer
in his current collection the fashion
designer flirts with his italian origins
this is beautiful because it's all
handmade and it's one of the gladiator
things and i love it so much because
it's really an italian masterpiece then
i go back to my roots and they say okay
let's start to study the roman mosaics
which are amazing all these geometrical
patterns all these geometrical designs
and i wanted to translate on prints i
wanted to translate as well
on knitwear and with a three-dimensional
effect
polizzi has always had a weakness for
geometric shapes
last year in paris he showed a complete
collection under his own name for the
first time
with great success
international stars quickly took to
wearing his dresses
such as american actresses cameron diaz
and jennifer lopez
and new zealand singer lord
polizzi became a favorite of celebrities
when he designed the costumes for pop
star madonna's stage shows in 2012.
celebrities this is much more a way of
having fun because i love them because
they want to be beautiful they want to
be sexy they want to be the best and
they want to be the best and they like
to do the best and
i like to play with them for this but
they like normal women all the women
celebrities not celebrities they like
everybody
and the fans love his eye-catching
designs
polizzi is considered one of the most
promising young italian designers
fashion journalists are already calling
him the new gianni versace
his shows attract the industry's movers
and shakers such as anna wintour
editor-in-chief of the american edition
of vogue anna de la rosso creative
consultant for vogue japan takes credit
for discovering it
i see the show as a successful blend of
sassy rebellious and punk
that comes to the fore here not so much
the rocker aspect that fausto became
famous for
the reason why i think he's so exciting
is because he's proposing something that
no one else does and he has his own
universe with this optical
geometric prince there was a lot of
black and white but he gave it a spurt
of color
and he's not afraid of being over the
top
palesi was interested in fashion even as
a child but he got his big break two
years ago
when paris-based fashion house onaro
named him their creative director
in 2013 he presented the first
collection of his own label in milan
for two years now the milan boutique joe
moretti has been carrying his
collections and his label is now
represented in 31 countries
a policy dress can go for between 1 and
10 000 euros
many customers come looking for the
designer's newest
pieces i always feel good in his clothes
i can wear them for any occasion with
sporty shoes during the day or with
elegant ones in the evening
critics have suggested that pulisi
copies versace
both love glitter and gaudiness but
polizzi says he found his own style long
ago
i want to be myself it's my amazon it's
my story i want it's i want to it's
fausta for years it's me
it's my dream i want to be me
fausto polizzi has no qualms about
casting a biker jacket all in gold
his new collection also includes pieces
that would seem right at home on a
starlet's hips
well almost four decades after her death
creations from the top mystery writer of
all time are resurfacing agatha christie
was the english crime novelist best
known for the 66 detective novels she
wrote under her own name most of these
reads revolve around investigations
including characters like miss marple
and aircool poro many say poirot the
fussy belgian detective is her greatest
creation and there must be something to
it because despite being killed off in
the series he's made a remarkable
recovery in the monogram murders
he's on the case again agatha christie's
hercule poirot
at the annual agatha christie festival
in torquay anchovy christie's birthplace
on the english coast he's the man of the
hour 40 years after his last case the
belgian sleuth is once again tracking
down criminals
and this woman best-selling crime
novelist sophie hannah is following in
agatha christie's footsteps
very excited yeah i mean this is the
agatha christie festival so this is
where all the fans congregate every year
and i'm massively looking forward to
launching the book here well you know i
figure if i drink enough champagne i
won't be scared anymore so that's my
strategy
agatha christie's many fans have high
expectations
her books have been translated into more
than 100 languages an estimated two
billion of her books have been sold i've
read every agatha christie before that's
why it's so exciting to hopefully have a
new one i'm curious i'm reserving
judgment
till i've read it
sophie hannah is also a fan to remain
true to christy's style without copying
she tells the story from the viewpoint
of a police commissioner friend of
poirot that was how it started on the
evening of thursday the 7th of february
1929
with hercule puerto and jenny and fee
spring
amid the crooked teapot huddled shelves
of pleasant's coffee house
the monogram murders is the title of er
cool poirot's new case
three corpses are found in a london
hotel
the only evidence the murderer has left
behind are the cufflinks beside the
bodies
stumbles onto the case by accident and
in true agatha christie tradition finds
the perpetrator in a group of suspects
it was sort of extra important to me to
write the best novel i could not only
for me but more importantly for agatha
for the family for the fans of prairie
all over the world but i think actually
that pressure was a good thing it made
me
absolutely in no danger of being
complacent and i think ultimately it
made me write a better book
agatha christie died in 1976
she had her star detective die in the
last novel she wrote supposedly to
prevent anyone else from taking up her
figure of aircool
it was christy's family that decided to
authorize another story and they chose
sophie hannah
cuaro is very faithfully reproduced he
likes food he's fastidious
all that kind of thing and yet
there is enough uh that comes from
sophie hannah herself to make it
original surprising and enjoyable
agatha christie expert john curran has
kept a close eye on the writing of the
new aircool puerto novel
he himself has written two books on
christie's life and work
i knew sooner or later there would be a
new agatha christie and while i would
prefer that it never happened at all
when i heard that it would be sophie
hannah i relaxed she treats the
character with respect and that for
all christie fans that is very very
important because agatha christie is not
just another crime writer she's an
iconic figure in the world of crime
writing
proof of that are the hundreds of fans
who make the pilgrimage to the festival
in christie's hometown each year
at the book presentation sophie hannah
was up against some stern critics
i'm a bit skeptical as i am with anyone
who writes a novel someone else began or
who uses someone else's character
but i've read the first 60 pages so far
and i like it
it might actually appeal to a younger
generation which they might fall in love
with the advocacy we
know the character may be over 90 years
old but her cool poirot could continue
to keep detective story fans on the
edges of their seats for many decades to
come
well a traveling exhibition showcasing
innovative handmade german goods is
currently making its way around the
world today we'll look at one of the
companies behind these masterpiece
products on display the munich-based
company is called windfall and it builds
expensive chandeliers from genuine glass
crystal
it's a new take on lighting
the crystal chandeliers in windfall's
munich showrooms are bright and brightly
colored
they're designed by clarissa dawn from
germany and hull jachmans from the
netherlands
they've taken this grandiose lighting
fixture and reinvented it
it's classic with a twist
there's the usual crystal and some
shapes and elements but the way we put
it all together and the illumination has
a new sense of airiness
the twist is done with small spotlights
which is how most of the chandeliers are
illuminated
it's an idea that has lit up big time
the two designers sell about 1 000 of
these creations a year
many are made especially to order
designed for the room they'll be used in
normally the functional input outweighs
the form factor
the lucid division
some of the chandeliers weigh a ton
when we're installing something of that
size in a casino like the one at
leicester square we have to be very
precise
right down to the last millimeter of the
millimeter stem
the chandeliers are built entirely by
hand in their munich workshop by
sebastian haiduk who is originally from
poland
he spends up to five or six hours on
each individual light
the crystal is sourced from the finest
manufacturers such as swarovski
working with such precious materials is
a challenge
these materials here aren't cheap
and when our clients order something
then what they get has to look good
quality is important to us
windfall was launched as a company 10
years ago today they have customers from
around the world many of their most
prestigious projects are in london like
this vip lounge at heathrow airport
and the restaurant at the royal albert
hall
among their current projects is a palace
in jeddah saudi arabia
a chandelier like this can cost up to
000 euros
we work for a very small niche which we
discovered 10 years ago
it's a design-oriented niche that
appreciates beauty
but the work the quality and the
attention to detail that go into our
products has its price
in berlin they created a lighting
concept for a luxury hotel suite
their chandeliers also grace the homes
of the rich and famous exclusive clients
looking for an exclusive adornment
it is a favish cut meter via
some of our designs are very colorful
and that's what makes us special
we're rather daring in our use of color
at first people found that shocking when
they saw it
but now 10 years on people have gotten
used to it
their office and showroom is located in
the heart of munich
the two designers draw inspiration from
city life and their urban surroundings
even though most of their clients come
from abroad they've also sold a few
items here in munich
like this chandelier which adorns the
showroom of a local upscale boutique
when you turn on the light it's just fun
we've had clients say that they spend an
hour at the dinner table because the
light's so lovely
by this
stream
traditional crystal chandeliers are
often heavy and look and feel
but in the hands of windfall's designers
they're transformed into one-of-a-kind
creations
delicate airy and contemporary
well it's time for a bit of sightseeing
euromag set off on for ulu in northern
finland it's a great spot to explore and
it attracts visitors for its beautiful
and peaceful countryside you can also
get your fill of hiking paddling and
mountain biking not to mention some
finnish tango
the region around olu is known for its
beautiful forests and lakes
the city itself is situated at the mouth
of the olyoke river
200 years ago uru was a major trading
center of woodtar to the rest of
northern europe
today the region draws visitors in
search of tranquility and beautiful
scenery
i come from mexico the mexico city so
there is like
absolutely the opposite right here we
were
walking around and sometimes there is no
one no human to be seen and it's
beautiful
from olo a ferry brings visitors to
hailuto still something of an insider's
tip
about a thousand people live on the
small island surrounded by stunning
scenery
among them ira's palkanon and her family
she also offers tours for visitors
people often ask me why is it so quiet
here did something happen
as soon as you get away from the only
road on the island it's absolutely quiet
all you hear is the wind and the birds
tourists can enjoy all the lovely
landscapes on view here
they can also digest nature's bounty
mushrooms and berries here belong to
everyone
this
we've already gathered 120 kilos of them
this season
reindeer also love the mushrooms
the herds belong to local farmers but
they're allowed to roam free
the animals are shy but they don't seem
to be afraid of cars
juhani vikkowin's family has bred
reindeer for four generations
he has a farm in taiwan about 150
kilometers from olu where he also offers
guided tours for visitors
usually they encounter a reindeer or two
but
usually there's a large herd grazing
here
but i saw a bear in the forest this
morning
so the reindeer are probably afraid and
hiding somewhere
reindeer meat plays an important role in
finnish cuisine
at the izociote hotel a two-hour drive
west of olu it's served in a traditional
way with lingonberries
and while you're digging in you can
feast your eyes on mount izociote in the
distance
the surrounding national park is a
popular place for hiking in the summer
and autumn
but winter is the high season here from
november to may there's snow everywhere
and lots of it there are all sorts of
ways to enjoy it from snowy hikes to
reindeer safaris
you're guaranteed snow here even if an
ulu 100 kilometers away there isn't any
the tourists come here to experience the
deep snow and the northern lights
the finns love nature so much that they
also socialize outdoors
their traditional dance pavilions are
usually situated by the shores of a lake
or river surrounded by trees
many host ballroom dancing once or twice
a month you can try your foot or
everything from tango to waltz to
traditional finnish dances
and local customs are important here too
the men ask the women to dance
two songs together and then the man
leads the woman back to the side
you don't have to talk when you're
dancing if you don't want to
hurry
up
it depends on whether you come alone or
with
so from the sound of it the locals in
finland know that silence is golden
and that includes out on the dance floor
that's all we have time for today you
can visit us on our facebook page and
let us know your thoughts that's it for
me and and the rest of your remarks crew
for now thanks for watching and we'll
see you tomorrow bye
so
you